[Music]
coming up on fyi do you feel safe
walking to school
we visit pupils in birmingham who face a
journey through a crime hot spot every
day
[Music]
and we'll be asking are we getting
enough of a break from the stresses of
school you shouldn't overwork yourself
like if you're really stressed you
should take a break
[Music]
this is fyi where we bring you all the
latest info and you get your say yeah
and this week we're going to be talking
all things school love it or hate it
it's a massive part of our lives but how
do we deal with the everyday stresses
we'll be hearing from fyi viewers and
getting advice from fyi psychologist
laverne antrobus but first we're gonna
kick things off with a couple of stories
that we found that could be fake news
can you guys guess which
[Music]
we found this photo being shared online
that shows ice melting in a jug of water
and the water level of the jug roughly
staying the same
the post is meant to represent an
iceberg and sea levels and suggests that
melting sea ice because of global
warming doesn't mean ocean levels are
rising but are the claims fake news or
fact
or is this photo with a 44 inch
cottonmouth snake in the usa real or
just good photo editing it was posted by
a member of an online reptile group and
then it went viral with lots of people
commenting that the photo wasn't real
but what do you think we'll reveal all
later
so here's a question what's it like when
you live do you feel safe if the answer
is no then it's actually not that
surprising we had a look at some stats
and crime is on the increase in cities
in england and wales gang-related crime
is a big issue in fact it's so bad that
there's a new scheme being tried out in
the west midlands yes so on 18 routes to
school pupils are walking together in
large groups with youth workers looking
out for them it's all part of a new
government scheme called step together i
joined pupils in birmingham on their
walk to and from school
[Music]
youth violence has been on the increase
last year there was an average of 590
offences in the west midlands every
month
but it's hoped that a new scheme could
step together won't just protect pupils
from gang crime but it will also drive
the gangs out of these areas
this is all about communities making a
stand
while we're all so unlikely to be
affected by gang violence this school
and others nearby have become a big
concern
the step together scheme is all about
safety in numbers with pupils being
accompanied by local youth workers to
school
so how big is the problem with gang
crime and anti-social behavior around
here it's a big problem we're an inner
city school
and we have a local park where lots of
crime takes place it's the second
highest crime rate in in birmingham so
we are very aware that we need to keep
our people safe around here because of
that reason
sadly in west midlands in the last few
years there have been attacks on
teenagers in the hours after school and
it's hoped that the chaperone scheme
will stop that from happening no matter
where you're from
what you're doing
we're here to help you keep you know
keep you safe
it's home time so khadijah has invited
me to join her and her friends on their
walk home to see if they feel safer
so do you feel safer walking home from
school having a chaperone definitely
because i feel like with the chaperones
here i know if something was to happen
there's people around that can help with
it do you always walk home with your
friends then yeah most of the time so if
i'm not being picked up i'll walk home
with a group of my friends about four or
five of us yeah because you can get
security walking with your friends
saying that there's more of you and then
especially on top of that having um
chaperones yeah
so what are your main worries
around this area there's quite a high
crime rate we've got like nearby parks
where a lot of crimes happen as well
there's a lot of stabbing and lifetime
going around this area there's gangs and
stuff as well so it's quite dangerous
so do you think that more schools should
follow this scheme yeah because i feel
like it'll help so many more kids and
kind of
decrease the amount of gun violence
that's happening around schools even if
it's not here bye-bye
will everyone got home safely tonight
the scheme isn't going to end crime but
it's definitely reassuring for us and
our parents
it's a shame we have to go to these
lengths in the first place but if it
does help with stopping violence and
crime more of these schemes could be
rolled out in schools across the country
soon
[Music]
so the feedback from some of the schools
taking part in the scheme has seen that
it has had a positive impact and they
hope that the scheme can continue into
next year well it's been a tough couple
of years at school for some of us hasn't
it
loads of us fell behind with work
because of covid and more and more of us
are on free school meals because
families are struggling with money so we
heard that the children's charity the
nspcc that rather children's helpline
childline saw a 33 increase in children
contacts in the service about friendship
issues with worries about falling out or
struggling to make friends so the
charity thinks we need a day dedicated
to what we love doing it's called
childhood day
this year they encouraged our schools to
take part in the big break time to give
us a chance to have a proper break and
just have fun and it's also to raise
money to help keep children safe
one of our fy news clubs even got
involved we're headed to bay artille
primary school to check it out
today at school we're having a
big great time day where we just have
loads of time to do fun games with our
classes and years we're doing like
handcuffing and hide and seek and
capture the flag how do you win the game
they're really fun to do because you get
to do it with your friends
i prefer these games because you get to
go out and have like exercise and at
home you'll just be like sat down on
your phone or watching tv
i think a childhood day is needed
because
children need to be happy and their
mental health needs to be healthy
it's one way to get children to play and
have fun and spend time with other
children they might not play with
normally you shouldn't overwatch
yourself like if you're really stressed
you should take a break
sometimes you can feel overwhelmed or
anxious if you don't take a break then
maybe the anxiety will take you over
i think we should be playing more
because like kids these days are always
on the phone like cooked up in the house
at my house we do like hide and seek
like every weekend
to like try and make it so we're not on
our devices all the time i also think
that even like playing some games on
your phone or laptop they're also really
fun to play too
not everybody can be able to afford
things that they like to do
there's lots of games you can play
without any money like for example hide
and seek chaos tag for football you just
need like you don't need much it doesn't
cost much to make you happy doesn't it
it just matters if you're having fun
[Music]
remember if you want to have your say on
an issue right here on fyi head to our
webpage at first dot news forward slash
fyi you'll get all the info on how to
set up an fyi news club at your school
[Music]
so really good advice there from fy news
club members but we wanted to get hold
of fyi psychologist laverne andrew bus
to have a bit more of a chat about how
to deal with issues in school harlem
thanks for joining us hi so what advice
would you give to people who are maybe
feeling a bit down about school and are
struggling to make friends or fall it
out with them so if you're falling out
with friends perhaps you've got to take
a bit of a look at what's gone on how
much might you be a bit responsible for
maybe you've you know said something you
didn't mean to if that's the case
quickly apologize and try and put things
back together
if you can't put it back together you
might just have to accept that you know
it's time to move on you know often you
make friends from looking around and
thinking about people who seem similar
to you but i think you've got to
remember the qualities that you've got
and be confident about that because once
you feel confident that will attract
other people towards those friendships
with you well over the past few weeks
we've seen quite a few reports that
because of the war in ukraine quite a
few russian-speaking children are being
picked on at school so what can we do
about that we've got to remember that
you know this is a conflict that
involves russians and ukrainians and
what we're hearing is that you know
they're not happy about this
so you've got to sort of call out any
instances where children are being
picked on we all know that's never okay
so more and more ukrainian refugees who
have fled the war i think have been
joining our classes and sometimes i
think we're a bit you know stumped on
that and don't really know what to say
to him i mean do we bring up the war and
ask them what they've been through or do
we avoid that topic of conversation i
think in these moments you've got to
trust your instincts a little bit we
can't really totally imagine what it's
like to be a ukrainian child who's here
at the moment we really can't so your
job really is to include them as much as
possible you know perhaps in lessons you
know help them sort out where they need
to be with their work or making sure in
the playground that you come alongside
them and they're not left alone so
basically you're treating them and
responding to them in the way that you
would want to be which is to feel
included to feel cared for and if you
are asking them questions about how
they're feeling please don't feel too
pressured about having the right or
wrong answers often when we want to
speak about our experiences what we
really value is just being heard well
thank you so much for speaking to us
levan that's really great advice thank
you
[Music]
braden check out this cool rainbow that
a fogger truck made in a city in china
that's awesome what's it doing it's
actually spraying mist to help reduce
dust and pollution particles in the air
the rainbow was just a cool side effect
nice
calling all theater performers how would
you feel if you got the chance to
perform and get feedback from west end
professionals well do we have the event
for you yeah it's called the junior
theatre festival and 33 groups from
eight different countries got to have
the opportunity we caught up with timmy
who went along with this theatre group
and wanted to share his experience with
us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey fyi there are so many of us here
ready to impress the socks off of some
professional actors producers and
directors by performing just 10 minutes
of a musical like cats matilda or once
in this island
everyone at the junior theatre festival
is just like me we are performing in
musicals at our school or in amateur
theater groups
this event is all about having the
chance to get feedback from the pros
as well as watching each other perform
and getting feedback there are also
workshops taught by top west end pros
but first it's time to show the judges
what we got wish me luck
[Music]
i'm part of bta west end a group
performing once on this island it's a
one-act musical set in the caribbean and
it's retelling the story of the little
mermaid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much for your beautiful
performances you should all be really
really proud of yourselves thank you
judge's comments seemed very supportive
and they were really helpful can you
feel that the judges said that we should
pass the baton on which meant that we
should pass the energy on through the
scene so that there was more momentum
and it kept going on and on at the
awards for achievement in dance go to
stagecoach abingdon
the awards show is fun at the end too
and some of us also get to perform our
acts on the big stage
theater means a lot to me because it
means i can just let go and just be
myself the junior theater festival has
really been such an incredible day
filled with so many amazing moments and
i cannot wait to take what i have
learned today back home with me
[Music]
thanks to me so how are your fate used
to texture skills with this week's
stories
[Music]
the photo being shared online that
supposedly shows no effect of sea water
rising when an iceberg melts into the
sea is fake news
sea ice is different to icebergs or land
ice
sea ice is formed in the ocean whereas
icebergs break off glaciers that are
formed on land from snow is this helpful
video made by nasa shows
so when temperatures rise because of
global warming and melt the glaciers and
icebergs it does affect rising sea
levels because it adds more water into
the sea
which means this photo of a 44 inch
cotton ball snake in the usa is fact the
perspective of the snake being closer to
the camera than the man but lots of
people thought the photo was fake and
that the snake was a lot bigger than 44
inches but the user posted more photos
to show it was a real snake
remember perspective can follow you in
photos and it doesn't mean the photo is
edited check out these people posing
next to the leading tower of pisa in
italy
[Music]
well that's it for this week's fyi but
as june as pride month a month dedicated
to celebrating lgbt plus communities we
wanted to finish off with how pride is
being marked around the world
lgbt plus stands for lesbian gay
bisexual and transgender the plus is a
very simple symbol that represents a
celebration of all inclusivity it's
about people coming together to show how
far gay rights have come and how in some
places there's still work to be done see
you next week
[Music]